I'm really pessimistic I don't think
there is a good outcome in 2016 hi I'm
Nick Gillespie with reason TV and today
we're talking with congressman Thomas
Massie a Republican from Kentucky
congressman massive thanks for talking
to us hey thanks for having me Nick we
are at the international students for
liberty conference tell us what are the
most important votes that are coming up
for a libertarian-leaning Republican
between now and the 2016 election I
think we can force some votes on the
privacy issue I've been able to force
about four votes in fact last year and
the year before I forced to vote on
appropriations bill to shut down
government forcing companies to install
backdoors and their products now that
amendment was attached to an
appropriations bill they got thrown away
and then an omnibus was later done but
it's important to get the votes because
then you can see where the congressman
stand what did you think about in a
recent Republican candidates debate all
of the existing candidates were like
Apple should unlock that phone and just
be done with it how do you feel about
that I'm sad I mean now that rands out
of the race the libertarian voice is
gone and I think it's also untethered
some of those candidates to become more
neocon ish in 2016 what are the
prospects were growing the number of
congressmen and Senators who like
yourself are serious about shrinking the
size scope and spending of government I
think the prospects are good there's a
guy in Indiana Jim banks who's been good
on the food freedom issue in in the
state Senate so I've decided to back him
and there you know there are other
candidates out there the real question
for me or my goal now are my mission in
life is when the good guys get elected
is trying to keep them from becoming
zombies when they get to DC because you
know we get probably 12 to 20 guys every
cycle that you know they run on what
they believe and they believe what they
run on and then they get there and they
sell out within about six months what
are the ways that you either keep them
from selling at or becoming zombified
what what what kind of is it education
is it support is it what congressman get
led to a place they never will
to go and then they find themselves
there and they find themselves trying to
argue that that's the right position and
so if you can explain to them how
they're going to get led in those
directions how they're going to get
whipped into voting for things they
never intended to vote for if you can
it's almost sort of like a dating manual
for adolescents like when this happens
and you feel uncomfortable there's a
reason you feel uncomfortable just you
know you the sort of need that dating
manual who can they get there so they
don't end up in places they don't want
to be in terms of the presidential race
what's the best outcome that you're
hoping for in 2016 I'm really
pessimistic I don't think there is a
good outcome in 2016 so the I would say
the the one argument for libertarians to
vote Republican that still remains is
the Supreme Court nominees other than
that I really can't see very much
endearing for a libertarian in these
Republican candidates so yeah I mean
you're not going to support or you're
not going to endorse anybody before the
election or will you vote for the
eventual Republican nominee I'm not
going to endorse any of the remaining
candidates and in Kentucky I'm going to
vote for Rand because he's still on the
ballot and you know we'll just wait and
see what happened in November what you
know we're at the students for liberty
conference what was the most important
issue to you and your student days and
is it still a big deal for you and if
not what is replaced it you know my
gateway issue into Liberty was gun
rights because I grew up in a rural area
where everybody had guns and then I went
to college and realized it you know that
people in college wanted to ban these
things I went to college in
massachusetts and so that was sort of my
gateway issue into into the Liberty
movement and as I thought through that I
was able to think through these other
and and the gun issue I mean over the
past 20 30 years is actually Second
Amendment rights have really seen an
enormous increase in their legal
standing as well as their popularity and
in many ways I think the gun rights
movement or political effort is probably
something everybody should study because
they're fighting above their weight
class and when when I was young if you
want to carry conceal
happen you had to be a sheriff's deputy
I mean it was virtually unheard of to be
able to do that and now you can do that
in most most states with minimal hoops
to jump through you know in 1994 they
banned so-called assault weapons and we
all thought in high capacity magazines
we thought we'd never see this again and
here we are they're the most popular
firearm in the United States and crime
and gun related crime and violence is
down that's important yeah every state
that has made these changes or
municipality to to be more liberal if
you will in terms of letting people own
guns they've seen a reduction in crime
what makes you pessimistic these days
and what makes you optimistic I guess
I'm most pessimistic about the national
debt in the fact that when interest
rates return to normal levels five
percent interest on twenty trillion
dollars is a trillion dollars a year
that's bigger than our military budget
it's actually our entire discretionary
spending combined and that I mean we're
spending about four trillion dollars a
year so if it goes up to that that's
twenty five percent off the top is just
going to pay money we don't have well if
the four trillion three of that is for
entitlements there's no there's a
trillion that funds the things that
people think about like roads and
bridges that you know NASA the military
that trillion will wipe out all of the
things that Congress actually votes on
because I don't see any will to change
the entitlement programs right now so
then what makes you optimistic what
makes me optimistic is technology and
invention and the human spirit to
improve our own lives you know I'm my
background is an engineer have 29
patents I have invented things and when
people say where children be better off
than we were let's say well absolutely
they will because society doesn't forget
the things that invented and we invent
more things and so you know we've got
smartphones now and we've got ebay and
things that really made life better for
us thanks to technology and so when
people say we're going to be better off
I say yes but it's going to be due to
the engineers not the politicians well
we will leave it there thank you so much
we've been talking with congre
when thomas massie from kentucky for
reason TV i'm nick gillespie at the
international students for liberty
conference